you know why don't we discuss arranged
marriage that's so [ __ ] happy talking
about a region and done a thousand
things done a thousand times but Jackie
is Indian saying they'd never get an
arranged marriage I want to talk about
why it's a good idea there's no way you
believe that's a good idea what would I
not think that it's such an antiquated
system okay first of all stop using big
words I mean I would never even let my
parents of course you wouldn't do I
don't know I could see the benefits see
that's why you're my dude no hook you up
with some old-ass monkey who won't even
eat the banana you know I'm saying yeah
but y'all know what I'm like the banana
okay but first of all that's the girl
you want to be white P can I also say
this nobody will ever introduce a girl
they care about to you so it's not
something you got to worry about I
thought you're full of [ __ ] have you met
Akash this is what he does he makes some
absurd claim and sticks with it until we
prove him wrong I don't understand why
I'm being antagonized like this guys I
think I use that word correctly all
right also if you don't believe me let's
do a little experiment I'll have my mom
set me up with a girl and I have my
friend set me up with a girl as long as
you're okay with the fact that I'll be
hooking up other girls cuz I know you're
really trying to throw it at me and it
might be an issue okay then it was real
we good bad Jewish okay done deal
I get the ugly one
yeah they both email me oh this is a
girl my mom sent me Wow man you don't
know anything about her she could have
an STD who cares look at her bio dad oh
she's got a residency and she's gonna be
a doctor
oh yes okay first of all stop flirting
with me
second of all I know but my mom doesn't
but we know that okay so I win your
friends okay let's look at the one my
friend sent me this is huge
at least you wouldn't be stuck with her
for life yeah but being stuck with a
water buffalo for two hours for life
she's not that bad she really does look
the point is I was right I told you this
is my show you have a date with a water
buffalo